when Final Fantasy 15 episode dusk a  demo released we got to experience a big  open world but the full game won't  always be like that in an interview with  Japanese magazine famitsu director  Hajime Tabata said that certain elements  will become less open as the game goes  on he stated Final Fantasy 15 consists  of both open world and linear parts the  first half keeps going as an open world  but the story in the second half is led  by linear path that way you won't get  bored of an open world as the rest of  the game Titans so we made it in a way  that you'll also get to advance through  it as you have in conventional final  fantasy games Final Fantasy 15 comes to  ps4 and xbox one on November 29th will  probably hear more about the game's  open-world structure between then and  now so stay tuned to gamespot for more  details and for all the biggest Final  Fantasy news you're already in the right  place  you